For computer vision object recognition,
we're inherently interested in
finding objects in images, okay?
And that finding means
essentially two parts.
There's sometimes one.
There's this notion of detection and
labeling, right?
So here in this picture of you know,
person standing next to a car,
I have to not only sort of tell you
what's in it, I have to say oh okay,
over here and I'll draw a box because
a lot of these things are Windows based.
Saying okay, that's the car and
by the way over here, that's the person.
So in general that's
what you have to do.
And the, sort of the most common
approach to doing that is referred to as
windowing methods.
All right?
So there are lots of different
ways of thinking about Windows.
We can start by thinking about
sort of whole images, right.
So, here I have a picture of a couple
of training examples of koalas and
a couple of training examples of pandas.
This slide borrowed from
Kristen Grauman, Kristen has a thing for
cuddly folks with big ears.
So if any of you are cuddly with big
ears, you can give Kristen a call.
I hope Kristen's okay with that.
So you know, clearly here I have my
koalas, we've talked about koalas before
about how they're not bears, right,
that koalas are these things.
And here we have pandas,
which are bears but are just mean.
Anyway, and we'd like to do is we'd like
to somehow learn a way of discriminating
between them and say, you know,
which ones are which.
So, one way of doing this would
be to just build some sort of
a holistic description
of the entire picture,
with the assumption, we'll get to this
part later, that the picture thing that
I'm looking at is mostly the koala,
or mostly the panda.
So what would be the simplest
possible description?
Well here's one.
How about I just build
a histogram of the pixel colors?
Now, I'm showing it here in a single
image so it's, it's black and white.
You can do this in R, G, and B, and
have, you'd essentially
have three histograms.
And you could imagine that basically,
you could try to determine that,
you know, these things look kind of,
pretty much different than this, so
that might be a good descriptor to try
to find where the boundary might be.
You might try something even simpler.
I don't know, if it's simp,
yeah, I guess it's simpler.
It's not a very good idea.
All right?
The same way we did in PCA,
you can take all the little pixels,
put them in a great big vector space and
you could say, okay, here are a whole
bunch of koalas, here are a bunch
of pandas, find me the boundary.
You know,
do you think that would work well, or
do you think that would not work well?
What do you think Megan?
Do you think it would work well?
>> No.
>> No, okay, one of the problems is,
you know, if I shift the picture just
a little bit, all those pixels move
around in that feature vector.
So a small change in the image is going
to give me a large change in my feature
vector, which is not something you
want to have if you're going to have
a good ability to discriminate
between them, so that won't work.
And what about the color thing well,
you think if I just did that color and
intensity thing,
that would work pretty well?
>> No.
Okay, look.
Suppose I make it brighter today or
there's a shadow being cast upon
the thing etcetera, whatever.
I get, you know,
major variations in sort of the
distribution of the intensities, okay.
Do you remember when we were talking
about trying to do tracking or
trying to find things you know, motion.
We were looking for
what were called interest points.
I hope you remember that, okay?
And if you remember interest points,
house features, those kind of things,
they were based on the idea of places
where you had high gradients, okay.
In particular, those were where you
had variations in the direction of
the gradients as well, and the idea
was that gradients corners were quite
robust with respect to
changes in illumination.
So if we take our koalas and our pandas,
we can consider sort of edges, contour.
The idea of these intensity gradients,
right?
Those things tend to sort of stay
where they are, in terms of, you know,
if I change the intensity.
All right.
But of course we do have this problem
that is, I move the image just a little
bit, I might get shifts in the location
of where those pixels are.
So now, remember sift features, so we
did that whole thing with sift features,
which took histograms
of the orientation,
and we computed these
little feature vectors.
Right?
Well here, imagine taking your picture,
and you just cut it up into, say,
four quadrants, right?
It's easier, right?
So, one, two, three, four.
And I,
suppose I just compute some histograms
of the orientations of the gradients
in each of those regions.
And I do that for
each of these pictures, okay?
It's robust with respect to illumination
changes because the gradient's there.
Is it robust with respect to
small shifts in the picture?
Megan, yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, it is.
So the reason that it's robust with
respect to these small changes is that,
you know, if I move this guy's
ear a little bit around.
You know, a bunch of pixels.
The distribution of the gradients is,
in that quadrant,
is going to remain about the same.
That's why down here it
says locally orderless.
What it means is that I'm not
worried about exactly which pixel
you're, you're in.
I've got a general distribution in, in
one or two different areas of the image.
Okay?